[Music]
in lesson learned news aha
submitted by golden hose that's tight
golden hose oh that's all you need the
team learned a valuable lesson about
over sharing on social media
good my sister needs over share a lot of
social media no you don't where's your
daughter
no what I okay well would you say he
over shares a lot and she says no you
don't and I was like alright I guess get
my ass eaten out by Jess is not over
sharing well you don't really you don't
think that's a big secret though you
don't you don't think that's a big
secret how do you feel about a Jesse
maybe just as the one I lived on not
being public information but have a
delicious ass yeah it's pretty sweet
yeah yeah how do you know just I licked
it before your ass her mouth yeah Oh
Jeff that's just my own juice is
covering the taste of your ass
it tastes like an [ __ ] gotcha he's
like our spring so we use that so that's
your natural you have a natural Irish
Spring so do you use Oh brand you put
shampoo on your bottle because I have
hair anywhere there the hair
what about your eyebrows my face - okay
we have to pause because when we okay
Evan Eaton is also like a year okay when
he when I thought it was a one-time
thing when I was he was shaving from
front to back he was like a seal okay so
he was not shampooing his hair don't
make it that disgusting Joe that's
actually pretty clean then I thought
yeah I thought because he was putting
shampoo on his ass hairs they had like
that bounce to them and shine oh my god
there was no hair at the time you're
shaving it he was like a waxed butterfly
Wow gotcha
all right so moving on I got acid I want
to move on dishes but they clicked on
the video for a reason so Jeff you don't
want it to go on either they got given
go on right guys okay mom let's do it
all right sorry I have to be the mom so
this story here 18 she posted her name
is Kylie she's 18 years old and she
tweeted resolution was ranked first of
all okay Kylie well which is Sharon she
tweeted this out would you like to yes
my bf cheated on me so I logged into his
snap and posted these on his story xoxo
enjoy so this is the first one it says
we were so good together before I
decided to stick my dick in someone else
y'all can hit her up now she's single
yep so that blew up and shortly after
church so that so the first one was on
June 1st but she put her boyfriend on
blast for cheating on her exactly on his
own snapchat and also on her Twitter and
so that was under first and then on June
6 she posts this my apologies for
causing such a ruckus just to get back
together with him in conclusion everyone
[ __ ] up we're all human I'm officially
canceled oh my god so so she did that to
get back with him back together so this
is the video
why should we do with that other one
she's back with him segment parent
winners Wow well they're young so I'll
give him that I probably looked like
that when I was 18 so that's cool sector
and he's wealthy with [ __ ] so that's a
cute boy see yeah she's hot yeah yeah
and that guy just looks like a regular
dude that likes vaping yeah or something
he's like Oh Charlies baby who's [ __ ]
say yeah hey have you tried strawberry
yet I met this guy man he's great
all Bennet that seems pretty good try
mine Pina Colada he takes those liquor
store dick pills yes the Rhino pill when
he's you like Serge hey I like the dream
chick rock star and this guy probably
drink some monsters so you're not that
far ahead of him you know I'm a police
true he does drink monsters and I dress
my age now oh very good now thank you
what is that 45 age dude you went from
like underage dressing to like you
skipped your age by 10 years yeah
working on it yes you don't dress your
age no yeah so that first tweets it got
over 66,000 likes and how many retweets
is all this one on Twitter itself yeah
and then there was actually a follow-up
tweet that wasn't mentioned here and it
was some other girls said oh yeah but
what about when you cheated on her Duke
helps my boyfriend cheat on me so like
she wasn't
and then it was all kind of like
everyone underneath that was like I was
rooting for you you know like yeah well
she seems like such a good person I'm
surprised she also cheats too so what's
the lesson that she ended up ok so then
she started getting a lot of hate DM
this one [ __ ] [ __ ] keep [ __ ]
around with fat ugly pigs that cheat on
you because you make them feel good
that's your standard and it's Paul's
yeah it's all you good for anyway
without that makeup you would look
identical to a witch so many other
decent man out there and you to choose
chose a pot-smoking Toyota Kyoto driving
cartoon characters shit's actually sad
guests your equivalent to him
I mean he's not wrong in the right he's
not wrong but you don't need to say that
to someone that was a guy I don't know
it's blurred out so when guys call
chicks [ __ ] [ __ ] they wanna [ __ ] ya
cuz they're like oh I wish you were mine
Oh Lord a [ __ ] yep and so I have to
hate you because I like you yeah I've
never called a girl like a [ __ ] like
meaning it more like [ __ ] and like
that's not like that's so [ __ ] weird
I never meant I did I can't imagine
calling a chick a [ __ ] cuz I'm like good
for you have sex yeah that's like
working I do write all this [ __ ] I'm
always like you're [ __ ] weird that's
the opposite I'm trying to get her to
look more like a hoe yes that's all I'm
trying to do I try to get Nikki dressed
like a hooker all the time yes actively
I had Nikki in heels walking through a
[ __ ] airport because I was like wear
heels I liked it it was part of a
[ __ ] video because I was I was
getting her to dress how I want for a
week and we just happen to be traveling
or that and I was actually you don't
have to do this yet and she's like no
I'm sticking to it because I said I
would I like what you think Nikki's
gonna be that kind of like okay never
she's like [ __ ] you you pray Yeah right
and then they have hate sex yes you just
described it really well that's exactly
how that's cool mm-hmm is it the spiky
shoes yes I love that [ __ ] man the spiky
shoes the taller the better the more
chicken giraffe walk around look like
looks like a baby [ __ ] giraffe devil
who are prada shoes yeah all right so
she tweeted I understand that the hate
I'm receiving is concerned quickly
Kylie [ __ ] Jean Haley Griswald
Griswald 97 that's it kylie is woke for
a second Oh called you sick so she said
I understand that the hate I'm receiving
is concerned from people who don't know
the proper way to show it in the ways I
can forgive him I can forgive all of you
I'll assure you all I am okay I am 18
years old I made the mistake of making
my life to public so that's her lesson
learned thing is that she realized she
made her life to pub know her lesson is
you made bad choices and then she got
exposed yeah the internet doesn't care
because no one knows her right but it's
embarrassing like in your own town for
sure to be like oh this guy cheated on
me until everyone and then like you're
the girl that stays with the guy and
makes these horrible like I think that's
more embarrassing yourself yeah like no
one's no no no the internet people are
gonna remember you in two days so I
don't know it's more embarrassing I
think in person to realize it so that's
that hope yeah so she was saying that
she had 200 followers when that post
went viral and now she has over 9,000
200 followers so not that much of a
cellphone those that helped her a lot on
her she's hot I see I don't think anyone
cares they just look at her and go
follow yeah I hope she post more
pictures they don't have to deal with
her in person and just get a look at her
oh that's the worst when you meet people
in person and oh you get to they have to
talk and oh my god oh my god like you
care of the present three girls and
purses anybody know I mean like we never
seen of his life girls do you don't fall
under this category I'm talking in
retrospect when I was single and looking
to date peace you know Jesus do you for
coffee
he loves to talk to you dude this guy
can't wait to [ __ ] talk to you he
won't shut the [ __ ] up about how he can
always talk about you yep that's why
this disc this realm upon you on your
bullying oh I'll butt out okay he said
that you guys have had talks like every
night this week
and then he's really enjoyed that she's
opening up a lot to me mm-hmm and me to
to to her yes a big problem I'm
discovering things that I've never
discovered before like love how are you
discovering that huh help help the
people who can't discover these things
how are you discovering these things are
you fishing for the credit the process
with her what's the process with her how
did you know that you love me after all
these years finally yesterday how did
you ring yes oh no just a week ago okay
just a week ago I realized because I
would say I love you to her well I
didn't I don't think I was he didn't
mean it I wasn't connecting yet I didn't
know what love was you know and then so
when I came back from Japan I was like I
wake up and I just like woke up with
some panic attack [ __ ] like sweating
[ __ ] thinking in a million ways like
like like [ __ ] man like should I kill
her should I not what be together what
should we do should I just kill a run
away should I kiss her right now could
just let me walk out the jillee
nah cuz nobody else could have you so
it's like that's how you knew that's how
you knew you loved oh that's really
beautiful
well yeah cuz then I started thinking
like like okay I'm constantly pushing
this girl away but she just won't go
anywhere
so I keep trying to kick her out but she
keeps saying why well that's just how
she loves you how did you because I'm
doing the same thing I'm trying to leave
but I can't and I'm like why why why oh
it's like because this whole time we're
trying to prove to each other oh you
know when we love each other
[ __ ] we've been loving each other look
at how long we've been together and
going through all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then I said okay what am I doing
wrong here that's not there's a bridge
that's not being connected
we're subconsciously here and going
through all this [ __ ] nightmarish
life why oh it's not that bad but I just
bring you this picture it's not toxic
like that but I'm like but like why is
it not connecting why does why is there
a level of lackluster Ness where I see
you and Nikki and stuff and I'm just
like man there's something there that I
feel and there's something lacking here
and it's not that I don't want that with
her I just don't know how to connect
that so that was a huge learning process
and I'm still working on connecting that
part with her but now I I feel it I feel
it going toward her and I'm like I feel
comfortable um and I feel open and and
I'm able to I guess express myself in
new ways that I haven't been before yeah
it's just hard to explain it's more of a
feeling yeah maybe I'll learn more and
be able to talk about it more yeah
that's kinda like what Casey said to me
cuz like how he was saying like you know
I feel like we've been in this gigantic
hotel all this time like in our
relationship and we've been on different
floors and like in different hallways
like screaming to each other like find
each other and then finally we found
each other so that's really nice I feel
like I feel like I feel like in our case
she's been throwing me a lot of like
hearts and I just been [ __ ] grabbing
him and punching him away and thorn in
it yeah trash with hearts like yeah and
he's just like yeah he's getting all the
points when you do that back up points
time
[Music]
[Music]